[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: With a whole
universe of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
KASLIN FIELDS: Hello.
I'm Kaslin Fields.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud,
where I focus on Kubernetes
and Google Kubernetes Engine.
Today, we're going
to be demonstrating
what it's like to get
hands-on with some Kubernetes
essentials.
And to guide us, we have
an expert, Anthony Bushong.
Anthony, would you
introduce yourself?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Yeah, happy to.
Thanks for having
me here, Kaslin.
My name's Anthony Bushong.
I'm a specialist customer
engineer at Google.
I'm focused on
working with users
who are trying to run
Kubernetes on GKE in production.
KASLIN FIELDS: Wow.
So you must have some
really cool insights
into how this stuff
works in the real world,
so I'm really
excited to see what
you're going to teach us today.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Definitely just
trying to build on the concepts
that you and Carter have
introduced in previous episodes
of "Kubernetes Essentials."
Specifically, we're
going to take a look
at how you can work with
namespaces and services
when something is going
wrong with the deployment
of your application
in Kubernetes.
They each have
respective properties
that we can take a look
at to help us debug
and help us remediate
whatever issue we're
running into in our
Kubernetes environment.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So what are we going
to start out with?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Well, for starters,
we're going to have a
sample application running
in a Kubernetes cluster.
And that sample
application is comprised
of a frontend pod, which is
fronted by a service-type load
balancer, so we have a public
IP address so we can access it
in a browser.
And that frontend
pod is communicating
with the backend pod.
And so the backend pod is
returning a whole bunch
of information and metadata
about the environment
in which it's running.
And we can actually see
here the specific requests
that the frontend is
issuing to the backend.
If we take a look at
the Kubernetes manifest,
we'll see here that they're
both represented by deployments,
and they each reside within
their own specific namespaces.
So in this specific scenario,
we have the frontend
that is managed by Team A,
running in namespace team-a.
And then we have the
backend application,
which is owned by Team B,
running in namespace team-b.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So here we have a website which
has a frontend and a backend,
and the frontend and
the backend are each
owned by separate teams.
And those teams are utilizing
different namespaces.
So what are we going
to look into next?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Well, we're going
to take a look at
the namespaces a bit
further so that we can
understand what constraints
could actually be defined
at the namespace level that
might actually affect the
deployments of our pods
and applications.
So as you can see,
namespaces are a great way
to divide the resources
within a given
cluster across various teams.
And namespaces give
you a lot of control
between what you can actually
access within a given cluster.
So as you can see here,
we have the frontend
is owned by Team A, and we
have a namespace called team-a.
And then we have the backend,
which is owned by Team B,
and it's in the
namespace team-b.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So let's take a deeper
look at these namespaces.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: So when
digging into the namespaces
within a given
cluster, it can often
be a bit difficult to
navigate and understand
which namespace you're
working against.
So the kubens tool
is a great tool
to show all the namespaces
in your cluster,
as well as which one your
Kubernetes context is currently
configured to interact with.
Once we know what namespace
we're working with--
team-b in this case--
we can run commands
like kubectl auth can-i
and define the
verbs and resources
that we want to interact with.
So if we want to
delete or create,
let's say, pods, we want to
be able to check and ensure
that we can actually
interact with these resources
in that given namespace.
And so once that
we have verified
that we have permissions
to the namespace
to interact with the
resources we need to,
we can actually
describe the namespace
and take a look at some of
the constraints that are
defined at a namespace level.
The first one is
resource quotas.
So it's a great way
to limit the resources
that a team can use within
a given Kubernetes cluster.
So in this case, we're
defining a pod resource quota,
and it's a great
use case for trying
to preserve IP allocation
across multiple teams sharing
the same Kubernetes cluster.
So in this case, we're ensuring
that this team can only
run five pods, which means
five IPs that it will consume.
We also want to define
resource limits.
Basically, these are
just limit ranges
that define our minimum
and maximum amount of CPU
that containers can request
when running in this namespace.
And it's a great
place to troubleshoot,
because either of
these could be reasons
why your deployment fails
or why your deployment
is being blocked because
there are constraints in place
within that given namespace.
KASLIN FIELDS: So
namespaces give us
a way to manage and isolate
resources on some basis--
in this case, on a team basis.
And there are also
controls in there
that we can use to
make sure that all
of the resources for
that team are running
the way that we expect them to.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Exactly.
Exactly.
Like limit ranges,
resource quotas-- these
are all things that could be
defined for various teams.
Role-based access control
is a really good way
to not just isolate
individual user access
to various resources,
but also service accounts
that workloads use
if they require
different levels of access
within the cluster, as well.
And this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
There are many things that
are namespace-scoped-- network
policies, for example.
That can be, again,
different constraints
that are defined for
where your workloads run.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So what are we going
to dive into next?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: So
we took a little bit
about what we can
do to understand
how namespaces may be
affecting our interactions
with Kubernetes.
So the next thing that we're
going to take a look at
are Kubernetes services and
how we can interact with them
to understand what may be going
wrong with our application
running in a Kubernetes cluster.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So let's take a
deeper look at them.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Happy to.
So if we take a look at the
frontend that we deployed,
we can actually see the
host that the frontend--
or the hostname that
the frontend is actually
issuing a request against, which
is the backend service that
is owned by Team B.
And so Kubernetes
services, as you've
talked about in
the past, Kaslin,
are a nice abstraction on top
of Kubernetes pods or replicas
of a given pod.
And so rather than trying to
think about a per-pod level,
we can think about
a service level
that maps to numerous
replicas of a pod.
And it's represented
by the objects
you see here-- pods,
services, and endpoints.
And so when we want to
troubleshoot something locally,
we can actually port
forward against the service
where we actually are,
again, port forwarding
interactions with our backend
to our local 8080 port.
So as you can see, I'm
going to issue a command
to localhost on port
8080, and we're actually
going to get a response
directly from our backend that
is running in the
team-b namespace.
So basically, when you're going
through the debugging cycle,
if you need to interact
with services locally
or things that are a little
harder to visualize with a web
UI or something like
that, you can actually
port forward it to your
development workstation
and begin to interact
with it on your localhost.
KASLIN FIELDS: So
services give us
a way to interact with
workloads running on Kubernetes.
We can run our apps in pods.
But if you have multiple
copies of those pods,
then how do you interact
with the workload as a whole?
And services give us that.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Exactly.
And you get a DNS record
that gets provisioned.
So again, you don't even have
to remember that virtual IP
or that cluster IP address.
You can actually
natively interact with it
with a DNS hostname
that gets-- or a DNS
record that gets provisioned to
kube-dns or your cluster's DNS.
And so it's really useful for,
again, clients within a cluster
to interact with
your application.
But it's, again, also
useful for end users
trying to understand
what's going
on with the port forward
command with kubectl.
KASLIN FIELDS: Nice.
So where do we go from here?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Well, we
showed a little bit about DNS.
See, now there's the age old
joke about how it's always DNS,
so I think it's important to
understand a bit more about how
we can interact and
troubleshoot with the DNS
in our Kubernetes cluster.
KASLIN FIELDS: All right,
so let's take a look at it.
What have you got to show
us when we're debugging DNS?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: So I think
the first thing that's
important to capture
and understand
is where kube-dns is actually
running within our cluster.
So we're going to
run kubens again,
and we're actually going to see
a namespace called kube-system.
And so kube-system is
where system pods that
are required for the cluster to
function, like DNS, typically
reside.
So if we actually run kubectl
get pods in grep for kube-dns,
we're going to see
a few pods running--
two replicas of kube-dns,
as well as an autoscaler.
So I think it's really
important to understand,
as your cluster scales up,
as your workloads scale up,
the number of DNS queries
also typically goes up.
And so typically,
you want to make sure
that your kube-dns pods are
actually scaling up properly
and are able to handle all
of the various volume of DNS
queries coming
from your services.
And so when something
is going wrong,
if you take a look
at this, we've
navigated to a YAML file
for a dnsutils container.
And this is actually giving us
a way to interact with kube-dns
without having to
package up tools
that we would use
to troubleshoot
into our application containers.
So once we actually apply
the dnsutils.yaml file,
you'll see that this
single pod called
dnsutils has been created.
And then we're going
to take and just verify
what namespace it's in.
And so we're going to
switch to cluster-utils--
again, a great way to
separate tooling we
use to troubleshoot from
application workloads.
Then we're going to run
the kubectl exec command.
And we're actually going to pass
in a couple flags, -i and -t.
And this is basically
a way for us
to kick off an interactive
shell within the dnsutils pod.
And the dnsutils pod
will have tooling
that we may want to use
to troubleshoot DNS,
like nslookup.
And so it's also
important to know
that, while you could get the
interactive shell by passing
-i and -t, you can also just
execute the single command
if that's what the
use case calls for,
and not an interactive shell.
So what we're doing
here is we're actually
testing the DNS resolution
for our backend service.
So we're using
gceme-backend.team-b,
and we'll see that we actually
got the cluster IP returned
to us properly.
And so once we actually
run kubectl get svc,
we'll actually see that
this is the same cluster
IP that was returned
from the DNS resolution.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So what you did here
is really interesting.
You created a new
pod within Kubernetes
that had these dnsutils
on it, and then you
used that pod to debug
what was going on
with DNS in the cluster.
That's really
interesting and gives you
a really nice way
to debug what's
happening with DNS
without even messing
with your other existing
applications in the cluster.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Yeah.
Exactly, right?
I think it gives you a safe way
to package up a set of tools
that you only need to use for
a specific period of time,
and then you can spin
it down once you're
done troubleshooting or you've
identified the root cause.
And I think this really helps
minimize what we actually
need to bake into our
application containers.
And that's useful for a
whole bunch of reasons,
whether it's security,
whether it's performance.
There are a bunch of
different angles and benefits
that we get from making sure
that we're not basically
causing bloat within our
application containers.
KASLIN FIELDS: So what else
do we want to go over today?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Well, I think it
was really cool to see the exec
functionality within kubectl
for our toolbox or
dnsutils container.
But I also want to show
that this is something
that you could do with your
application containers,
as well.
So we'll take a little
bit further look
as to when we would running
an exec into our application
containers.
So kubectl exec--
great for utilizing
with utility or
debugging containers,
but also can be used with
your application containers,
as well.
This is useful if
you need to take
a look at the environment
in which your application is
running.
KASLIN FIELDS: So
if something's going
wrong with your application
as it's running in Kubernetes,
we can use this tool
to dive into them
and figure out what's happening.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Exactly.
So just building
upon the example
that we have in this
video today here,
we're going to take a look at--
we're going to switch back
to the team-b namespace,
and we're actually
going to take a look
at our backend container
or our pod here that's
running serving our backend.
And we're actually going to run
the same kubectl exec command,
and we're going to
provide the pod name.
So in this case, the
backend production
pod with a specific
hash at the end.
And then we're going to kick
off an interactive shell
once again.
And so this is a way
for us to understand
what's going on in our
actual runtime environment.
So I just ran print
env, and I can actually
see all of the different
environment variables that
are configured within this
environment, this container.
And so it's really
useful if you need
to take a peek at things that
might change or want to verify
that things are correct
within the actual container
that you're running.
And another thing that's
interesting about this
is that, going back to, again,
the conversation of creating
minimal containers, sometimes,
you actually won't even
have a running shell
or something that you
could initiate a connection to.
And so in those
scenarios, kubectl
has actually added functionality
for mounting a debugging
container into that running pod.
So if you don't have
a running shell,
there's actually relatively
new functionality
that enables you to still get
that interactive environment
where you can do things like
check environment variables
or other things that might
affect your application
while you're troubleshooting.
KASLIN FIELDS: Thanks
for that demo, Anthony.
You covered a lot of
really cool stuff in there
and a lot of tips and tricks
that even I didn't know.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
And I really think
we're just scratching the tip
of the iceberg here, right?
I think I just really wanted
to take a look at namespaces,
and services, and
some of the essentials
that are important that folks
interacting with Kubernetes
should be aware of when trying
to figure out when things are
going wrong, why
they are going wrong,
trying to remediate them.
But, of course, there's so
much more to dive into, right?
KASLIN FIELDS: Today we learned
about how Kubernetes namespaces
can help you isolate and
manage resources-- for example,
on a per-team basis.
And we learned how services can
help you reach your workloads
and can help you debug them.
Then we learned some
great tips and tricks
for debugging both networking
problems from kube-dns
and how to get into
your applications
to debug them using kube exec.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you want to
explore more, we'll
have links to additional
resources in the description
below.
And be sure to like and
subscribe for more content
from Google Cloud.
We'll see you next time.